les canadiens pourront éventuellement
obtenir un passeport en quelques clics à
partir dans le téléphone cellulaire
d'une tablette ou d'un ordinateur ibm
canada va créer ce nouveau service à
même le nuage informatique d'amazon le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu indiquer où
seront hébergés les données personnelles
des canadiens et rien n'empêcherait ibm
de les utiliser pour effectuer des tests
à l'étranger même si c'est une compagnie
américaine qui s'engage à garder les
données localement au canada le cloud
acte fait que les données pour être
éventuellement transférés hors du canada
si on regarde l'historique d'amazon on
constate rapidement que cette
entreprise-là fait très souvent de la
revente de données de ses utilisateurs
ce son modèle l'enfant de base amazon
web services ni vendre les données de
ses clients et garantit que sa
technologie est sécuritaire une porte
parole indique que l'entreprise s'occupe
de la sécurité du nuage informatique et
que c'est au client de s'assurer de la
sécurité des données qui s'y retrouvent
n'empêche selon plusieurs experts cette
modernisation du service de passeport
pourrait être une manne pour les réseaux
criminels
les passeports canadiens permettent une
mobilité qui parmi là la meilleure qu'on
peut retrouver à la surface de la
planète donc c'est très attractif
les fraudeurs et les cyber criminels
pourraient tirer profit d'une faille
dans le système
ils vont l'exploiter très rapidement
très intensivement pour essayer de se
procurer le maximum de passeports de
façon frauduleuse dans un minimum de
temps
mais ces problèmes pourraient être
évités si le gouvernement faisait appel
à ses propres informaticiens selon le
principal syndicat qui les représente
les fonctionnaires spécialistes en
informatique sont capables de développer
des systèmes très performants gérant des
données très sensibles et la
sous-traitance risque aussi d'entraîner
une perte d' expertise au sein de la
fonction publique sol messieurs qui fait
que au départ après so de ses ressources
à l'externe ibm canada n'a pas répondu à
nos questions
quant au gouvernement il assure que la
sécurité des renseignements personnels
des canadiens est une priorité ici est
elle cotait sroka
radio canada ottawa